اقر وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي ايي كوهين
بمسؤوليه الحكومه الاسرائيليه عن هجوم
السابع من اكتوبر واعرب في مقابله صحفيه
مع صحيفه معاريف الاسرائيليه عن اعتقاده
انه يجب بعد نهايه الحرب انشاء لجنه تحقيق
حكوميه مستقله لتحديد المسؤوليات ومحاسبه
المقصرين واضاف كوهين ان اعاده جميع
المختطفين الى ديارهم التي وضعتها اسرائيل
هدفا لها يمكن ان تكون من خلال شيئين
مجتمعين الاول هو الضغط العسكري والثاني
هو الضغط السياسي واوضح كوهن ان الحديث عن
الاستيطان في قطاع غزه سابق لاوانه ولم
يكن ذلك هدف اسرائيل بل كان هدفها استعاده
الامن في المقام الاول حسب قوله ولفت
كوهين الى ان اسرائيل لن توافق على سياسه
لا تخضع فيها السلطه الفلسطينيه او اي جهه
اخرى للرقابه واشار كوهن الى ان لدى مصر
واسرائيل مصلحه مشتركه في الاستقرار
الاقليمي وفي الحرب ضد ما سماها المنظمات
الارهابيه وبراي وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه فان محور فيلادلفيا بات في
السنوات الاخيره على الارجح مصدرا لتهريب
الاسلحه والمعدات القتاليه الى قطاع
غزه